okay so we're gonna book five now we've
looked at all these other virtues these
Aristotelian versions we didn't we
didn't look at all of them in as much
depth this I didn't like but we got to
look at several of them and explore you
know who would they apply to what goes
into them and now we come to was
probably the most important virtue ball
which is justice and Eric saw the ball
so what book - why does he give a whole
book - justice well there's a couple of
reasons that we'll see and this is a
good place to start with this this
notion of Justice being an ambiguous
term some of the translations that you
see a Marisol and I call this an
equivocal turn but ambiguous is probably
worried that you're more used to you're
all familiar with something that
somebody says to you being ambiguous or
somebody saying that what you're saying
is ambiguous you have some general
notion of what it means and that applies
to this question we started asking at
the beginning of Plato what is justice
remember the Republic was about the
whole question when is justice first
they started out with well justice is
being good to your friends and being bad
to your enemies who turned out to be a
few problems with yeah although you
notice that coming back up again here
with reciprocity that images came out
with this very radical view justice is
the interest of the stronger or the
advantages
and we looked at some problems with that
man who actually we got to this this
notion of Justice of being sort of
balancing within within your soul and we
thought in terms of our appetites this
spirited element and reasonable aerosol
is going to ask this question again and
every important thinker in ethics and
political philosophy and in quite a few
of your other fields if you guys are
studying criminal justice majors
constantly having to rethink this
questions what is justice business
majors you may not necessarily think of
this but it's fair you're asking you
know there's a lot of majors where it
won't come up as immediately as that but
design majors you know how much time
should you give to one particular
project or later on I'm gonna how much
time should you get into one particular
client as opposed to another client
that's a question of justice that's a
question of fairness right if any do you
ever become teachers which I imagine
some of you bill
some may end up finding an avocation for
teaching K through 12 and so maybe they
become called a professor someday you'll
be posed with questions of justice it's
not it's not going to come out like that
you're not gonna save yourself just
thinking to be B in this case they don't
ask yourself things like should I follow
throughout this obligation what would be
fair here you're constantly getting kind
of problems
you're out how you should allocate your
your scarce amounts of time and
attention what counts it's fair when
you're dealing with students you know
should you give one student who seems to
me the attention much more attention and
the other students these are these are
all sort of questions concerned with
with justice actually so many who have
exercised leadership
Ras any of you have ever been in charge
of a club or would also be like that in
college club officers are a is anything
else that comes to mind those leadership
positions for you guys team captains or
coordinators or things like that right
those involve justice as well because
you're having to determine who gets what
and how to decide cases so this is a
really important question and Aristotle
is going to take a different tack than
the playdough did or a birth
certificates or polemarchus he's not
going to have one single answer that's
why he says this is an ambiguous term
when you say something is ambiguous
you're saying it has been more than one
meaning so take an ambiguous word in
English or seal what is that what's the
one single medium of seal or is it one
single being how many beans
I said let's see what came to your mind
first
yeah one 8-ounce advances in the circus
for face of warrants what are they like
other animals
look you so that's what I'm eating
oh yeah things that they've lost things
but yeah every state has one of my
counties yeah no you see I got a podium
the president gets up and gets to the
presidency okay so that's another one so
we've got two meetings yeah you can talk
about sealing an envelope when I was a
kid they had this thing called see let
me know it was this gigantic thing that
you would have these banks are like you
know we're using our freezer minutes and
you put your food in it and then you put
it into the ceiling the old thing push
it down the heating elements it would
melt the plastic but they call the
seal-a-meal because you were putting a
seal yeah so already we have three
different mediums that that means that
the term is ambiguous now if I say I saw
steel in the zoo which would steal
anything
yeah if I say President Obama gave a
speech and I could see the seal
thing like a crest some sort of animal
if I say somebody needs to fix that seal
roof you don't think there's any animal
up there has to be fixed you think of
some sort of coating or something
closing or something on so you know how
to handle ambiguity when it's terms that
you're familiar with
now notice with with seal those meanings
are pretty far apart from each other
they're really easy to tell apart right
when it comes to justice and the
meanings are closer together so it's
harder to tell them apart Aristotle is
going to distinguish a number of
different kinds of justice it's really
easy to notice those up and this is why
we get into all sorts of confusions and
this is why we get into arguments as
well about what's right and what's wrong
well oftentimes Aristotle says they
doesn't say this so much and in this one
but in other parts of us works in
politics he says a lot of times when
we're arguing about justice what we
don't realize is each of us is hardly
right good law so think of it this has
the oldest person a is getting this
amount person B is getting this amount
they agree on this apartment here and
person ain't a stats on getting this
portion he or she actually knows exactly
what justice is person B is actually
seeing a side of that that the other
person isn't seeing and of course
they're typically also saying yeah
you're completely wrong - you don't know
what you're talking about
only this
Aristotle says probably if that's what's
going on you're going to end up in
people compost a lot of disagreements
with each other the best thing is to
actually grasp all of us and the only
way that you can really have to give
that is by taking a look in I'm going
through and seeing what falls under
justice what actually is imprudent and
once what's not there's a few other
things that I'd like to sort of point
out just by by a comparison with this
there's all the terms that we use that
are like this to I think for example
freedom this freedom always mean exactly
the same thing there are multiple senses
to this to it's it's also an ambiguous
term your freedom that you enjoy as a
kid freedom from worry
you probably don't enjoy life you have
other freedoms you didn't have as a kid
precisely why you're subjected to
anxieties because you actually need to
decide where you're gonna live what
you're gonna do what you're gonna eat
who you're gonna hang out with all these
these things you know whether you're
gonna go to class or not you probably
didn't feel like it much of a choice
about that package
well so that means freedom has different
senses there's other meanings of freedom
that you might not really think about or
come across until until later on when
you encounter situations where you're
untrue I think I may have mentioned this
this example friend of mine she was
considerably older than me and she'd
been a hippie in the 1960s and 1970s and
that you know that meant a certain kind
of lifestyle and being very free not
tying yourself down with relationships
with a job that you were gonna stick to
forever you know rising in a career
owning a house having a mortgage all
that sort of stuff today and she she was
in her 40s then she owned a cafe that's
that's how I knew her and she said
something really interesting one day
while I was working there
she you know the cafe was struggling and
businesses are harvest are there a lot
of a lot of headaches and she looked at
herself she said you know I never
finished college yeah so I don't have a
degree I never saved any money because I
just did whatever I wanted like she did
you know backpacked across she backed
all the way through Mexico down to Peru
not all of us have those sort of
adventures buckles come with a kind of
clause so she enjoyed you know
freedom one sense then later on she said
you know I look at all my friends who I
thought were squares people who did what
wait you guys do stayed at school plan
to get a job you know probably get
married settle down rise in your career
and she said to herself she said it me
I'm so on free now because they've got
the things that they committed to that
they invested in the after tops they
have college degrees they have families
I've got nothing except for this
business and this is I feel I can tell
how I'm creating well I think she was
talking about freedom in a different
sense don't you what do you think
there's different meanings here's
another word that might some of you are
art majors design majors - majors beauty
I'm sure all of you have given some
thought to what is the definition of
beauty and you struggled with that and
probably came to the conclusion that
there isn't one single definition now I
want to put one other thing out - about
this you get the fact that these don't
have a strict one single definition
that you can pin everything on does that
mean everything's up for grabs sometimes
we talk like that don't we
a beauty thing I had a beholder is that
really true that beauty is purely a I
have a beholder that there are no norms
to it whatsoever those of you who are
art or design our fashion majors or
anybody else was interested in and you
know art music literature anything go
whatsoever why not that's a little
harder why not
could you come up with multiple meanings
of beauty then we sat down we sat down
can you come up with six or seven
different overlapping definitions why
some things are you know who's not fit
snug poorly sighs I wouldn't call this
great product design would you this
could probably be you know much more
attractive a few new definitions you
could explain why well it's gonna be
that way with justice when we get into
arguments about what is justice we want
to be able to tell something well here's
what justice is and then if they say to
us oh so that's all there is to it if
we're eros all the way to say no there's
more to it than that
this is one kind of justice so today
what we're going to do is explore these
different kinds
so let's let's turn up waiting yes legal
justice what is legal justice being for
Aristotle one way of thinking about this
right off the bat is following the law
right somebody is Allah by in person do
they break the laws if somebody's a law
breaker but they probably have under
some of the laws because I don't think
you could possibly break every single
one I mean we just boggle the mind the
efforts that you would have to go
through to do that but you know what
separates law breakers from lighting is
it just the fact that one breaks the law
and one doesn't break the law or is it
more - yeah you go wall breaker usually
I think if somebody did intentionally
breaking the law or something to follow
along dancing going out of their way to
try and knock that's an important
distinction there are some of those to
talk about in other cases of ignorance
there's probably a lot of water it's in
our society that's so many
marginally there's probably someone we
might end up breaking not realizing but
there's also news about copyright fair
use
inside and out I'm somebody who uses
documents for a living that's different
than saying oh yeah the one is screw the
lawn and do what I want or I'm gonna
break this watch just because you know
it's there what about being one is it
enough just to okay
I think he's saying I have to respond to
the fact that people are saying I'm a
hypocrite because I want the laws to be
enforced about opportunity education or
those sorts of things and you know I'm
breaking the law that's why I'm in jail
they arrested me and all these other
people for breaking a law against public
gatherings with how many permit and so
he has to explain himself why is it okay
for me to break the law in this case but
whatever has to follow the laws was
known there is a genuine time
there and he says well those blogs are
unjust laws they're not there for the
common good you can distinguish between
just and unjust laws main breaks and
Thomas Aquinas to make sense of this
let's assume that the laws are set aside
to understand I think you're about to
they have some sort of conception of why
let's think for a minute about some of
the other things that he's saying he
says that the laws if they're set up if
you have a society with the laws of it
they command us to do things that are in
accordance with virtue and they forbid
us to do things that fall under the
vices so you know they don't come right
out and say you have to be a virtuous
person you have to be a vicious person
but they promote virtuous behavior and
they tend to curb
rewarding the other so he has some
examples that we probably can't relate
to that law in our society like for
instance there was in ancient Greece you
get a city-states if you're a man page
and what was particularly important
about that was when they sent you out to
battle you didn't throw your shield away
and take a lot at stake this isn't for
me
everyone needed to actually stand up
we're sitting fine courage courage so
the laws Direction was on the book that
that had to do with things like you're
not allowed to throw away your shield
why because your shows kind of important
to invest just like if you're in the
military today one thing you don't you
know lose track of is your your weapon
that's been issued a lot of trouble if
you lose your weapon
why so there were there were laws about
that and what Aristotle says is the acts
requiring courageous actions as
forbidding cowardly dashes and then he
brings up another one that I think maybe
we can relate to a little bit better he
says a lot of the quarter temperate
actions and forbid in temperate actions
and he uses the example of adultery now
you know in our time adultery in most
states is no longer illegal it used to
be illegal which means you can actually
have fines
jail time for being an adulterer not
just you know getting divorced some
other good actually face sanctions in
the military installers and in some
societies you know it can get you killed
to have sex once you're married to have
sex outside of marriage bond or to
seduce somebody else's spouse have very
nice sanctions it was a problem in
Aristotle's time to this is the laws
forbid adultery yet by doing that
they're promoting temperance yeah
they're trying to curb integrins we
would probably expand it more to when
you see adultery things sexual cheating
they don't necessarily in our society
have to be married we recognize thing
most of us right that if you're in a
monogamous relationship with somebody
else the general you ought to be
monogamous stay with that person you
want to leave that relationship you can
promise you tell them ahead of time
start doing anything if they do that you
know if they do something about that
don't you you see somebody else cheating
at something else that bothers you I
think it also means that you shouldn't
go and seduce other people out of
monogamous relationships and they should
your partner so you know they would they
would fall under temperance he says the
laws also require good-tempered actions
or violent actions things have to do
with anger what do we do what do we tend
to do and were angry with people
the laws actually forbid that don't they
generally just because somebody looked
at you the wrong way you can't go up and
smack them people do but then the cops
come and take them away right you can't
get into an argument with somebody and
that settle it by punching them out and
not face consequences you can't do it
vicious action he also talked about not
not slandering the other word that he
uses in drinkin's literally not to say
bad things about them that's something
we're tempted to do or to visible and
this would cover like libel or slander
so here's something to think of that
would you say that our lives there was
that we have in our society and still
fulfill this function promoting virtue
and urban vice think to the virtues that
you've been studying the laws require
you to be a temperate person
like what
well like you mentioned violence is
strictly prohibited but that's not a
matter of temperance temperance yes it
is physical
are you referring to simply really be an
attempt Rijn so like drinking me so like
you're only allowed to drink a certain
limit before you pretty much would go to
do
to drink and drive well honey drive
that's double you wouldn't done that's
public drunkenness yeah you one thing
that's one thing one thing that's really
interested in knowing things a lot of
these laws are not like public
intoxication even the DUI laws those are
fairly recent just two generations ago a
lot of them yeah I think that would
probably be a good instance making
certain drugs illegal and then making
other controlled substances
yeah yeah and actually a great example
again something that we changed recently
used to but used to be needed by all the
cost share for one do that and generally
people who are buying closure by the
case are taking it you know that I do
you happy by a single one does the law
so you're right intoxication there would
not like it has to be consent so that
establishes a yeah
saying you can't go seducing spouse down
in South they still have something
called alienation of affection which is
a kind of weird way of saying if
somebody comes in and screwed up your
marriage you can actually sue them civil
court for monetary damages which you
have to do with governing certain types
of sexual practice that most of them
overturned yeah so a lot of the laws are
promoting diversity lien bridges we have
a different conception of walk it's more
like those are the rules of the game
okay
Aristotle's working with a somewhat
different conception of law that's why I
wanted to lead you through this to get
you to to see that let's think about a
few other types of ones that do try to
modify our behavior and arguably try to
make it to better people what about laws
governing say domestic abuse again a lot
of this is fairly recent stuff
that's what gets interesting and this is
very very much my jurisdiction
sometimes you know sometimes it does
depend on the person pressing charges
right and then other times the
prosecutor says I don't care press
charges he's in the system now I'm gonna
press charges so the very very much
depends on a lot of discretion place
here he's got any marks maybe they don't
take any or maybe Ellis everybody goes
to jail but the laws that we have on the
books with it are they trying to change
behavior or they just operatives from
like guardrails don't go any further
than this I think that would also depend
on what sort of support systems to
counsel to lead them through the process
so they don't say just recant it was all
a misunderstanding
what else ya think it's not a motion
that is like no sexual assault
coby's between like older men well
they're definitely laws against that
yeah and I think when you're thinking to
support I think now yeah that's an
interesting point that Cueto offered
once a when when some sort of here's the
thing you're Istanbul is is quitting out
and sing about justice and injustice is
virtues and vices unjust people
typically act unjustly they don't just
do it one time you know made a mistake
or something like that it's part of
their character so they're going to be
unjust in this way and then unjust in
this way child child abuse sexual abuse
child molestation is a great example of
that because generally the child
molester has a totally skewed view of
reality where somehow they're the victim
and the children are seducing that and
what they're doing is they okay and it's
those authorities out there who are
really hard to get everybody else when I
taught in Indiana State Prison one of my
friends who is teaching in another
he thought in a wig that was entirely
sex crimes so a lot of child masters and
so we would teach these philosophy
classes and quite a lot of them there
were child molesters mixed in with the
general population sometimes you get
kind of a weird vibe about a guy in your
class it was always sort of challenging
things and always wanted to undermine
things and tried to you know control of
the classroom in a strange way and I
would always go and look at people's
cases up after this semester just to see
you know the psychology of most
murderers pretty straightforward the
psychology of a child wants was much
more tangled and their sense of right
and wrong it's much more secure so
aerosol that they saw the other day it's
clear incense lights they not only do
bad things they justify it they say oh
no I'm not doing bad things it's a
matter fact you're doing bad things and
interfering with me doing this this
friend of mine he taught an entire
classroom it was almost impossible to
effectively teach in part because of the
dynamic and this you know people who
routinely commit injustice who have
unjust characters
exacerbating this is what sentencing and
sentencing
by the way so quite often injustice nice
and this isn't something Aristotle
standing this is a very interesting
point off-the-wall psychology quite
often people get away with doing the
wrong things and then you know they get
away with it because other people make
allowances for they enable that they say
oh no you didn't really mean it it's
just this one time
that's why Arizona makes this big
distinction they noticed between the
user already used this distinction is
there's a certain point where he
actually distinguishes between
committing and unjust an act which
clearly is wrong
yeah the person should be able to see
that it's wrong now they may not
actually be unjust they may have done it
because somebody forced them to do it
at the time or they found himself unable
to stand up to their appetites but
they're not completely unjust the unjust
person does those were the things
characteristically conditioned and then
there's committing over something that
is in fact wrong that does harm or hurt
somebody but there's less intent there's
less and less to do with the person
who's viewing circumstances and then
there's you know there's total mistakes
you know it's not the same thing as
committing injustice now people who are
habitually unjust who have that vice or
viciously unjust will often course other
people or take advantage of other people
so as not to have to suffer punishment
punishment could be judicial punishment
the punishment could be social
disapproval they make other people out
to be the bad guys so you know if we
take domestic abuse what's one of the
things that abusers will often say about
their victims
they hadn't come yeah and quit and then
sometimes they'll go so far as to
actually say oh no they're the abusive
one they get me when you know it's the
other way around
and you can almost always find somebody
who will be willing to believe that
because we don't want to believe bad
things about people so to go to these
sort of cases where somebody comes
forward and then they say this is hard
to believe that this this person
molested me or this person beat the hell
up or this person stole this money from
somebody who's a pillar of the community
and then other people start coming after
it takes courage for that person to
actually be able to do that because
quite a lot but that person has been
committing on injustice for quite a
while getting away with it that's part
of who they are and they've got the
reason why they get away - they're
surrounded by all these people who are
making excuses who are covering up or
enabling them we're looking the other
way and getting those people to change
their views on that that's tough isn't
it
people don't want to hear that at first
tell somebody that their their their
cousin their brother or sister is an
embezzler or uses their spouse
with their kid after the other yeah a
lot of them like bar like 34 years old
now the guys like from Penn State so if
you think about it at that time
comfortable going out because of the way
society would actually use not the
priests and that committed the crime
and that's what's most interesting you
know I feel like it emerges because you
were talking about like how laws have
changed or perception as well perception
at that time if that happened I'm sure
the guy wouldn't be prosecuted but they
would have been like scoring and there
yeah pretty much like nobody would want
to hang out with him and so forth but
now I guess since they came out saying
that and there were some younger
appearances with people now I guess it's
kind of like more okay like societies
you want to help them rather than mark
them yeah you know an interesting
corollary to that is if we're looking at
the best abuse right so a lot of this is
a problem with many underreported
victims have a sense of shame walking
when the laws have been made well
Aristotle thinks they should actually
steer us towards virtue and away from
lies
here's something I'd like you to think
about we're not going to explore this
too much in this class session you think
the laws that we have in our society you
think that they you guys know know what
the virtues and vices are do you think
they're well set up to promote virtue
and to try and steer people that applies
or do you think that they just produced
maybe conformity
you know we're ready to do a little an
expression you think about the laws and
your only attitude towards them do you
feel that the laws of your society both
of those virtues that you've recognized
yourself together do you feel that those
laws have shaped you into Hamill's
reduce do you think that they have
steered you away from vices and the laws
made you a less angry person
I think you're probably right
I mean unless you you are an
extraordinary circumstance why not
this yeah I think there's something to
what you're saying this make sense to
the rest of you that now law means
something more for you you can guiding
your behavior than it did say that you
were 6 10 14 again here juvenile
delinquent 14
since that time if the watch talked to
you to work on your virtues and get rid
of places you couldn't think of them in
terms of brooches and like soon they
just bought yourself wow I'm gonna get
my anger under control or and they need
to eat less need to exercise more stuff
like that does the law actually
oh yeah they're kind of they influence
in certain respects yeah I think you
guys remember earlier on in the semester
he said the walk and cannot make a meal
of me I can't make a person behave it
can make them not kill me though
and that's that's an achievement so
legal justice it's justice it's not
justice as I make full sense and a lot
of times people try to get themselves
off the hook by saying hey guys I
satisfy the law and in breaking laws
therefore I'm a good person just as good
as this guy over here this is this woman
over here who are you to judge me I
haven't you know haven't violated any
any written norms you know there's a lot
more to being Justin than just not
breaking the law
that's ourselves playing so this leads
us to the next thing we started talking
about hurt you
Aristotle says justice is also complete
version or the whole of virtue and you
know when you first read that you
might've said Wow then why did you have
me read all this other stuff about these
other virtues if justice is the one
virtue that covers everything why are we
messing around with that and why are we
looking at all these other ones in depth
courage the courage is the kind of
justice why not just look at just me
temperance is just a kind of justice
Aristotle says that the fully just
person in a way has all the virtues
wrapped
and he says this about a few other
virtues as well this is where we get to
talking about the unity of the virtues
justice requires the development of good
character traits Sophia therapist of the
adjust person habitually requires that
we develop some of the other virtues
because if you think about this this
makes good sense it would be difficult
to to be just if you're motivated by
certain vices wouldn't if we talk about
the greedy person the stingy person that
person wants wealth too much and they
make they make themselves kind of a
nuisance to other people your friends
the larger society by taking more than
they get well someone just people or
some greedy people are going to do bad
things to get that money
we're going to break the norms of
justice one thing that Aristotle says
about this justice is virtue so it's
bersia
it covers all the other virtues but it
covers those virtues as he says in
relation to others so what is this this
as opposed to just in your own private
affair
to just dealing nothing's by yourself
and I think that this is kind of
confusing it's confusing not only for
students studying and for the first time
it's still confusing for those of us
they've been reading for 10-15 years in
the Greek and keep going over this
passage because so many stuff that he's
saying doesn't seem to fit that well
some of the virtues that we've looked at
are already oriented towards others
everything like generosity that's not
about it is a little bit about you know
how you manage your money and that's for
you it's really about giving other
people right
are you generous if you give to yourself
what do we say about people who said I'm
gonna give myself a present you know
no they could give us somebody else you
know so I don't know if generosity or
magnificence would necessarily fit under
this that well the virtues that have to
do with with the ambition they might not
fit that so well either because ambition
is already in relation to other people
right if I find ambitious that means
that I want to get power position
prestige those sorts of things
and those are always relational so I'm
going to get power yes from power
overview if I'm going to get prestige
that means somebody's got
looking up to me right so I need some
other people so I don't think that it
fits that but there are some virtues
that it does it's one thing to be
courageous for yourself right
and you guys have all experienced having
to stand up for yourself against
opposition or having to face some sort
of danger or some adversity some
physical hardship or having to overcome
some fear that you've used it public
speaking as an example but I'm willing
to bet that another great example some
people don't feel this sort of fear but
a lot of people have to sort of process
through it asking somebody out on a date
for the first time or even just calling
somebody interested on the phone I
remember but if you don't do it at all
shy away from it then you know that
cowardice maybe you never we're applying
for a position that you're maybe not
totally qualified for grow into that
might scare
it could be a good position you don't
have exactly
maybe they'll chew you out for even
asking but then the more that you do it
the easier it gets the more you develop
in a dispositional courage but that's
for yourself either in cases where you
have to be courageous for other people
somebody would mention some of these
journal entries can you talk about your
own courage what are some cases where
you have to be courageous for another
person
but also would like like the verbal
signs if something is too yeah you know
it's interesting if you look at exactly
the sort of thing you're talking about
where somebody's being run down and
unfairly attacked I mean here's here's
something to think about people who are
abusive who are unjust who eventually
want to take more than their fair share
who want some warning others to the
power to force them into things that
they don't want those sort of people
don't usually just do that they also
have a lot you know it's not really my
fault that person's the aggressor a lot
of times of people cheap you know in
relationships they say oh the other
person was cheating on me
or they were emotionally unavailable so
it's okay for me to cheat or you can
with all these other sorts of things so
in you know in the the sphere that we
live in this public sphere we often
unless you know something about each
other's business Facebook has made it
even more so that's right there's people
who posted all sorts of things about
each other it's quite a walk in the case
that things get misrepresented a good
person gets called a bad person you know
if if you actually once that if you
actually call up an person on their bad
activities what's usually their response
to you you guys I think that what
happens
they say oh you're great shouldn't have
done that I really need to perform my
character
what's more awkward and sometimes you
know that's sometimes their friends
attack you and pretty soon you're the
bad guy for standing up for yourself or
for standing up for somebody else
so courage is really needed in social
life courage they actually stand up for
what's right professional like lawyers
who even if they know their clients are
wrong yeah they're defending them
whether they be just or they I mean
because I know they're getting paid for
defended with the case that's an
interesting case because in our society
the way that we set up the legal system
and it doesn't have to be set up this
way but we first talk about this one we
have this adversarial system where the
prosecutors duty is is not just to put
people in prison or finding good
fighting some guilty but to find the
truth the prosecutors job is to do yeah
and the defending attorney is is just
supposed to look out for the interests
of the client and we say that they have
particularly duty even if the client is
guilty to give them the best defense
possible
I think Aristotle would be willing to
recognize that because we've got the
system set up that way we're stuck with
it so the defense attorney is not unjust
by doing his or her job well but they're
not just as they they could I think you
would say our system is not particularly
and so that you know there could be a
lot of cases where your culture or your
legal system or even a family are
dysfunctional and it's great to steer
people and having to make these
difficult choices between some injustice
or some other justice what about
temperance
I mean temperance has to do with your
body and what you put into it
you can have much salad as you want but
you can't put ranch dressing on the
Scout that a little time right if you're
trying to lose weight or you can have a
lot of little meals through the day
that's you know but they probably
shouldn't be 3,000 calories why do
people do that because food tastes good
and why do people like that who's that
makes food taste good right sugar makes
food taste good if you're going on a
little carb diet and then you've never
done that then little character stuff
you start to creative carbs apparently I
think I like carbs too much now that
wants us to do with you and that's good
I mean if you develop the virtue of
temperance great I think that everybody
shouldn't have it is it is it possible
to think of the virtue of temperance in
relation to other people should it
govern well then let's say we just take
food not not sexual relations because
that looks pretty easy to think of how
that yes to other people right
just food are there are there reasons
whether there are situations in which
your temperance would be in relation to
others rather than just bearing on
yourself
what about if you make your food choices
based on where the food is coming who's
benefiting and who's being harmful like
you know coffees creating the
epidemiology of tray of coffee so what's
up what's all that about then you buy
Fairtrade coffee
well yeah I mean being a farmer you know
fair trade rolling agricultural
you know his whole food ethics
yeah
our Comment agribusiness and you can
find that with food production with milk
production with grains
fields they're actually owned by these
big corporations yeah I mean there could
be an ethical dimension to what we're
eating and drinking if you're buying
Fairtrade coffee I don't know if it's
guaranteed that all the profits are
going to go where they're supposed to go
but you're out it's making an effort
right you're you're exercising something
and that that takes some motivation and
that takes some habit-forming to do
doesn't it I mean if you're having a
something a coffee wherever it happens
to be at the juice press you're not
going to buy Fairtrade coffee you're not
going to be concerned if that's where
the time you actually have to go out of
your way sometimes if you want to make
food choices that would tie in with
temperance understood in terms of
justice not just understood in terms
what about anger managing anger does
that have any social dimensions or even
this is not necessarily society what
about in your family your own family or
even your own relationship you know
there are some people who get a lot more
of my ounces made and a lot of times in
dysfunctional families you'll see there
will be like one person who is the
rageful person and everyone else kind of
I know stays stays in the periphery it's
a void angering them and Arizona would
say that's a bad situation
that's an unjust situation in which the
lack of virtue of the one person with
respect to their anger is actually
affecting not just them not just their
relations with the other people but the
entire small community that is the
family
I need to think about this with teams
you can think about this with classes
you can think about this any sort of
group that you're in there's some need
for us to cultivate at least some
control of our anger hopefully you know
becoming prevention whatever gentle or
good off to do - especially at your age
it'll get better this time there's not
because I'm part of your who we talked
about this before the part of your brain
it's not completely finished growing in
Britain for the impulse control by the
time you're 25 your brain is actually
finished growing you'll probably have
some but I saw most of it yes that comes
from counting right that's to come
through virtually now the Eversole also
says something that's interesting about
this this idea completed Justices he
says you can look at the motivation why
people commit unjust actions uses
adultery as an example let's expand this
would call central cheating because
we do recognize this if you're in a
monogamous relationship and you're
committed it's wrong for you to cheat
right it's wrong for your partner she
got you it's wrong for somebody else to
come in from the outside and try to
seduce you or your partner be wrong for
me to give in to that it's wrong for you
to know what to do somebody else on a
monogamous relationship we do recognize
that as a marriage is we get upset one
of the motivations that people could to
do what sort of characters with you show
he talks about somebody who commits
adultery or Secession cheating and they
do so I'm motivated primarily by sexual
pleasure they can't you know they can't
stay with their partner because they
want more pleasure than their partner's
giving that or a different kind of
pleasure or who knows what else they
actually are going to lose some of their
resources in order to do that we would
say that that person is actually
motivated by fund advice of intemperance
then they and that's that kind of place
what if they do it for money
what if they they do it just for gain or
what if they do it well I wouldn't think
of other cases while some people cheat
if it's not just to enjoy a sexual
pleasure what's probably another one of
the bigger
y'all people because they're unhappy
yeah you in one way they don't like the
relationship there again that would be
the trying to seek pleasure I'm not
getting enough pleasure out of this one
find pleasure elsewhere sometimes they
do it to hurt the other person right I
think that's probably the second biggest
reason they could be they cheated on me
finances promises that they made I
haven't showed that is what makes Jerry
Springer that would be acting a banker I
think what if you did it just for the
money just to get something else
monetary oh that would be an adjustment
Aristotle says it's possible to be
unjust yet during certain contemporary
actions or certain angry actions for
certain other actions what about
somebody who turns their back on the
people that they're supposed to defend a
cop who isn't courageous when they're
supposed to be and leaves people at the
mercy of criminals because he or she is
paid off are they just a coward or are
they actually unjust Aristotle would say
they're unjust if they let people at the
mercy of the criminals because they were
too
get in there and stand up there would be
a color but if they're actually doing it
because they were bribed and they're
staying out of that area
dad they would be unjust so that's
probably enough about yeah let's look
now at some of the particulars justice
give you beyond the legal troubles
there's what Aristotle calls
particularly justice talks about three
different types of particular justice he
talks about distributive justice and
this could be is gonna be part of the
legal system some mechanism I'm there
anybody can all go back to
ridiculousness
yeah sometimes part of the legal system
you know sentencing old Criminal
Procedure and just to give you sort of a
thumbnail sketch distributive justice
gas to do with how we allocate good and
bad things among people or within
relationships rectification justice it
comes from the word meaning to set
things right so when things have
actually gotten screwed up somebody's
got too much somebody's got too little
Ben's justice means setting those things
straight and then reciprocity is giving
back to another what you're getting or
something comparable to it could be good
you know so somebody takes you out for
lunch you reciprocate by taking them out
for lunch as well or by providing them
you know nice print of something that
they like was sending them Thank You car
that's reciprocating thank you probably
guys watch did they do something bad
reciprocating somebody semantics you you
smacked that that's reciprocity right
now in all of these there's another set
of terms that are important or set of
concepts that are important growing up
and these are quality or fairness and
proportionality sometimes things should
be everything should be you know in the
middle that's the meat everybody getting
the same sometimes it's not strict
equality sometimes it's what he calls
proportionality so that everybody gets
what they deserve
according to some sort of criteria and
that's something irrational like I'm
taller than all of you so I should get
more respect yeah that would be an
irrational type of proportionality I was
going to be unequal but the question is
is there a good reason for why there's
no equality so let's start with
distributive justice let's look at that
first distributive justice it has to do
with good and bad things and allotting
them within context a personal
relationship groups society as a whole
how do you distribute those sort of
things first let's think about what sort
of things we're talking about what are
the kind of good and bad things that you
can
is that Texas is a bad thing right good
good for the government you're good for
those of you are benefiting from it but
we all tend to look at it as a loss
right and you're right yeah taxes can be
apportioned fairly or unfairly you know
there's all these proposals of having
altered forms of the tax system like
some sort of flat tax where you which
things you're going to tax to tax
consumption basic consumption items and
everyone has to buy do you tax luxury
items how much of the income should go
in taxes blue those are all good
questions so actually let's focus on bad
things first what are other bad things
that can be fairly or unfairly
okay yeah that's a good example I hope I
never have to do jury as soon as they
find out I'm a college professor for
this I think Criminal Procedure - we're
just talking about the reasons that they
don't want people and stuff like that
and like it's like a drug page my Mike
shows prosecutor would want like moms
with children and like yeah like Girl
Scout leaders and things like that I
just like people that are like that that
people that you can rely on to decide
the way that you would like them to
decide the reason why somebody like me
would get rejected is because they have
no idea
yeah you know I can time to talk about
this issue of the jury what Spears
you know and sometimes they'll try to
balance the jury as far as race gender
socioeconomic class well so we have jury
duty taxes you know they're gonna sort
of governmental booths or other things
yeah I mean if you like that work that's
not yeah let me put it to you this way
why do most students not like doing
group projects I didn't like very
possible for me I'm afraid
yeah my favorite statements requests
years ago this is what it's going to be
like in the real world and I'm like no
they get fired in the real world if they
don't do this
you end up doing all the work and you
nothing today you're doing a little work
you still can't absolutely yeah you put
your finger and the problem there's two
main ways things that wonderful you
could just get sad but usually what's
that result well they don't read the
tough it'll pay attention in class I
mean they could actually be genuinely
but that's more office they're the ones
that live here we a second time
they expect everybody else if you if you
put people into a group and you say okay
here's the assignment we need to do this
a lot of technical it's sort of like
look at each other at first islands
somebody will take charge somebody else
take charge right let's see where this
goes
oh no that strike Susana okay nothing
yeah all of you I think all of you
pregnant stories like that it's not for
Maris that leads from high school
how do professors get around that you
know professor actually wants to be fair
even from the members of the group
that's good that's good that's that's
the sign of somebody who is enacting
whatever some would call distributive
justice you should get the bad
ingredients we put in the work should
actually get the rewards from those who
don't do anything shouldn't get anything
that's so you sometimes you need to have
processes by which you can actually
figure out how to proportion so a bad
way of doing group work is just assign
group projects everybody needs to send
great because it's not in line with
distributive justice you know another
thing they need to distribute that we
are thinking about is risks or danger if
for example we send all of our trash and
pollution and stuff like that off to
some other group of people because they
happened before that would be putting
them at a great risk right prepared us
probably would violate the norms of
distributive justice as far as in our
society true if that was indeed the case
that strikes me as kind of unfair you
know put some new jersey residents at
greater risk if they're you know there's
other things that were involved with and
it puts some people that risk losing
their houses
that at all many distributive justice
would say there ought to be a
corresponding or work for those people
something proportional and what about
good things when we get this tree what
are some of the good things
what's up well well yeah that's a big
one should for example a doctor get paid
for their work than an unskilled laborer
stacking engine parts on pallets what
that's pretty important they save lives
yeah that's a very big function
I mean conceivably if the person stance
is Joe yeah there's other people who
might save lives who we might also say
shouldn't get paid as much as the
doctors with you know police and
firefighters in some places don't get
paid enough I think maybe they should
get paid more but probably not as much
as doctors why not
what else is what else is brother what
is the doctor
yeah they had to put themselves through
through four years of undergraduate and
then how long is med school whether four
years and the Gator battles Indiana
that's three years right three we can
see so that's 11 years
yeah it's usually in the hundreds of
thousands getting it on the Parkers med
school so yeah there's probably a good
argument for the doctor getting paid
more for their services then we can do
this with a lot of different professions
maybe there's some professions that have
paid too much
maybe there's others that aren't paid
enough we would have to make some sort
of reasoned argument for why they ought
to get paid more and a classic we want
it to be in line with distributive
justice what else coming Sheriff candy I
bring in candy should I should I give
which I just throw it at random like
they'd like to do you know crates throw
in the air and whoever catches one what
if I only throw it over at this side
that's not very fair well you you could
that you could rectify it
yeah what if I come in and I say okay
everybody who's wearing light colors
it's five candy bars everybody's wearing
dark colors everybody who's wearing dark
colors gets one candy bar anybody who
can test it it's no candy bars that'd be
fair they're rather a rational way of
dividing up candy bars
yeah in Reverse the distribution started
slowly away from you propagate you got
so ask them maybe like distribution of
knowledge is a good thing meaning
everybody equally gets a chance
go to school and learn ah now here
actually you're not going because it has
to do with equality opportunity one of
the things that we we think it's very
important is that everybody at least in
our society and societies like ours is
that everybody has the chance to be able
to do something doesn't mean that
they'll automatically succeed bankroll
until they actually deuces particularly
we tend to look at that something that
lot to be equal not just abortion
although when you know when it comes
down to getting more selective should
everybody who applies to med school be
allowed to go to med school they reject
some applications people who have
crazily off-base assessment of their own
skills
yeah we know that Joe what do you call
the what about affection or attention
you think that could be a matter of
fairness for justice in society
let's say you kiss if you will probably
be tempting to apportion the affection
unevenly some kids are quite frankly one
of pain they're kids you know maybe you
want to give them less affection that's
almost a the actual thing isn't it you
like people who aren't easy to get along
with with any fair though you're a
parent what about you know somebody says
I'm sorry little Suzy I can't go to your
dance recital because this week I've got
two little Tommy's soccer game and Cub
Scout meeting and tuberosa they would
strike this is very unfair enough to say
yeah that would be a question of
proportionality there you would have a
legitimate reason to
greater needs I like this kid more in
this kid last that wouldn't be a reason
for proportion parents do we do that
with friends student okay we're gonna
hang out
who are we to stay in touch with a lot
of these things come down to
distributive justice let's go ahead and
rectification justice so rectification
justice that's a hard word to keep
saying right tripping over it means
setting things right so think of it this
way
when somebody has wronged another person
when injustice has been committed
somebody has gotten too much somebody's
gotten to them so for the game in terms
of the balance of you know justice with
scales the balance has been shifted that
now it has to be brought back and
there's a lot of ways in which this
could be experienced I think it's useful
the way that Aristotle he actually
distinguishes the different hang on
cases he talks about voluntary
transactions or relations like business
connection it's like you go into the
workplace you don't have to be in the
workplace
nobody's chaining into your desk pretty
good case in society I think that some
of the other things
just like friendships a marriage you
probably also say things like sports
teams applause that people are involved
with or good examples oh I forgot to
bring out the students talking about
housing with respect to rectification
justice actually let's start with how
many okay so that's actually a really
good example back in the common space
right everybody has to use it they don't
get cleaned up the weekends some kids go
out they come back details of cost
investigations right in a way they're
doing something wrong they're taking
more than their fair share of the public
space and they're leaving it in a bad
condition after the wrecked Ithaca Tori
justice I mean one way to set that right
word maybe if you make them do it and
clean it up
an upperclassman never like marks
learners I really am sad eight guys use
more than one person wall that's
Darrington
yeah and then I'll go in for my
inspection of Emma necessarily
disgusting you guys but if you want to
march through every place why we're
talking about Friday we're never
watching it yeah
yeah well you know it's an interesting
story somebody else comes along things
up so much well yeah because they're not
balancing things out by fixing in part
because what's going on to this somebody
has gotten more than their fair share
and that somebody want to be somehow you
know lowered or have less of that if
somebody else comes along who does the
work for they're cleaning it up for her
she's not actually getting back her
share you know another way might be like
finding me
actually dusting the biggest problem
yeah I mean people
a that warmer walls were always really
thin so there's always be some some
dummy who came home at 2:00 in the
morning blasted their stereo and you
know what are they doing there they're
in a way taking more than their fair
share of of time
was it part of this exercise routine
maybe it's some sort of strange
obsession I mean you guys could probably
we could do like a whole class period
just on problems with the dorms right
and how rapid the Katori justin should
come in look we'll think about this with
some other frameworks you know what are
the some of the too much too little that
would come in I guess that would be like
sharing
you know I think you know that could be
off the elves and then maybe somebody if
they're going to have it beyond bounce
maybe they should have to make up for it
some other way
what about like housework one of the
common complaints is who tends not to do
enough power
still today out heavier and like kind of
immoral but if you get what it's out in
that way
well it's not bigger questioning not
everybody looks it well your generation
is better for this my generation my
generation is way better than previous
generations but but the sociologists of
studies it is still somewhat unbalanced
maybe there's some need for you know
fairness in that maybe somebody's
getting too much there are all sorts of
things we didn't think about in terms of
us let's go on to to reciprocity so what
is reciprocity I said it was giving back
what your yeah your assault I said
something really nice for us as human
beings we naturally want to be able to
do when somebody hurts us we talked
about this with the anger we would like
for them to get hurt too and for we
would like to see somebody else hurt
them
the old notion of an eye for an eye
tooth for a tooth
that is something that's very strong in
us there's no sir naive conception of
justice associated with that that could
be at odds with some of these other
kinds of justice there could be times
when an eye for an eye tooth which if
it's really not what is going to set
things right
just going to perpetuate so maybe
somebody strikes me and breaks my jaw
maybe I don't get to go on break third
you long we have somebody else will
break through on recovery maybe they
have to pay for my hospital stay and pay
me some damages and pay for the wages
when it comes to good things we want to
be able to reciprocate and we often feel
ourselves if we can't do that too you've
all heard of the notion of poetic
justice right well what does the poetic
justice we've said somebody's that
that's poetic justice somebody's got a
poetic justice
usually when yeah but when they're like
something like like for example somebody
who seems fair that seems appropriate we
feel Canada sense that things have been
you know put back to the way they should
be
it's not quite the same thing as
directive
to adjust us something in some ways a
bit more perfect yeah the notion of
karma in the full sense consequences of
one's actions attached to ones yeah are
we saying that then if we agree that
somebody's she do a lot on somebody else
and she cheated on is okay when we're
saying that wasn't just so it's okay
this person's own house because they're
a super unjust person that wouldn't be
the right thing the right thing would be
for them to get branded every person who
cheats and nobody wants to go ahead and
date them or have anything to do yeah I
think it would be somebody like heiress
that would say that would be the
gorgeous right because reciprocity does
capture some aspect of justice just like
legal justice capture some aspect but it
doesn't capture I think
just yell so talks about the the
importance of reciprocity in the social
mind and connecting us up with each
other and they're very much less
involves equality what does economic
exchange yes such is a matter of
misoprostol what do we feel as a fair
price for something when we're getting
equal value for what we're giving right
and this doesn't necessarily have to be
Goods it could also be services let's
say you're swapping services somebody's
going to come and clean your yard oh you
know you could pay the money or you
could cook them dinner right there could
be a matter of reciprocity you might
actually say and your dinners not that
good but I'm not gonna clean your yard
for them so your yards five acres or
maybe your dinner is really good they'll
say oh do your yard twice for that it's
a matter of finding the sort of equality
and it's not strict equality
it's proportionality he's got this
example of a shoemaker who trades five
pairs of shoes for one pad I don't think
that's very easy for us to relate here
although actually it probably would be
about the same
I think there's a lot of other things
would be good and step we're trade-offs
that you make in your life the students
do they give you anything back for that
hope they do it at least you know praise
you're a good person for helping me on
like this that's the cheapest coin maybe
you know maybe if you help somebody
write their paper they should they
should take you out for dinner
Oh what's your thinking maybe then you
know that's one of those things where he
doesn't think about what would be
exchange the last type of justice that
he talks about we're not going to go
very far into this is what Greek it's
fp8 and this is a different type of
fairness it's something that modifies
the Babel justice one of the problems
that we saw earlier justice is a person
can follow the law without really being
just inside and sometimes if the laws
are set up certain ways they can be a
bit rigid can't they you think of any
examples in our society of laws that
someone unduly you know rigid and how
they how they treat people so sometimes
in justices take place by following laws
yeah well I don't know if this applies
you tell me after they're put on there's
like a different there's different
penalty for like powder cocaine and then
saw yeah yeah where the penalties for
powder is is more no it's less no yeah
you're right it's less but solid it's
more and like the people that can buy
the type that's less touchable are those
are like typically with white males for
that sort of rich but rich people yeah
yeah let's all get like higher powers
yeah I think a lot of people see that as
unjust unfair they're not saying that
everybody should walk all the time
they're saying there's there's some
unfairness in the way is being done
where you could think about some of the
three strikes and you're out laws you
know where the third strike would be
pretty minor infraction equity is a
modification of legal justice that
tempers that says well in this case now
I'm in every single case but in this
case we should last night we should be
more flexible
Aristotle compares it to the type of
ruler that they use which is made out of
left and so if you wanted to measure the
things that were perfectly straight you
ruler that putting is like that compared
to this straight no wood so he says all
was universal bit about some things it's
not possible to make a universal
statement which shall be correct when
the watch speaks universally in a case
of high design which is not covered by
the universal statements it's right to
correct the omission same with the
legislature wouldn't set so you look to
them with the spirit of what was the
purpose behind this and this goes to
what you were saying excuse me at the
beginning of the class understanding
what the law is therefore what's the
good that it's supposed to serve this
becomes really important than things
like family for some some areas of civil
war where there's a lot of need for
equity or I think in terms that we would
more often used today we call this
discretion those of you who are in feels
that business or justice ready to use
this term that's that's also a type of
justice looked at a bunch of different
forms and you notice that if we want to
understand justice as Chloe put all
these together so that's where we leave
off have a good weekend I won't see you
Tuesday